[Music]
finally the bells of big ben
bring brexit in with a trade deal taking
the uk
out of the european union the end of a
relationship that dates back nearly half
a century
brussels had set the time midnight in
belgium 11 o'clock here in the uk
the eu had already made its other
adjustments
with only a day to spare the trade
treaty had been
signed and sealed within the shores of
this island
nation british politicians say
sovereignty has been fully restored
the political slogan we must take back
control
had gone down well with the majority of
voters now it's going to be put to the
test
it's got to be better we need to govern
ourselves and be our own bosses
there's going to be a lot of stress
between everyone anyway because it's a
very
unknown and people don't deal well with
change
in legal terms it was 11 months ago that
the uk left the eu
nearly a year of transition followed
with a trade deal now in place
brexit is set to show its true colours
the uk may have its brexit done but
there's still a lot of haggling ahead
the fisheries agreement seen by many in
the industry as a sellout
won't come to proper fruition for five
years and that will be subject to
negotiations
decisions still have to be made in the
services sector which makes up 80
percent of the economy
and it includes financial services and
data sharing
there won't be any new taxes to pay on
exports at the border
but there'll be plenty of bureaucracy
and delays are likely
everyday freedoms will also end new
rules on travel
immigration mobile phone use bank
accounts to name a few
and there are big implications for the
future of the united kingdom
the scottish national party promised to
restore eu membership to largely
pro-eu scotland if it becomes
independent
northern ireland is the only part of the
uk that will continue to follow many of
the eu's rules
that's to avoid the return of a
contentious hard border
with eu member the republic of ireland
but that means
new checks on goods entering northern
ireland from the rest of the uk
unionists fear isolation i think the
deal has made northern ireland place a
part
we wanted to come out of the european
union the same terms as the rest of the
united kingdom
sadly that didn't happen for four and a
half years brexit split the country even
dividing families
those tensions may well have subsided
but now the clock is ticking on a new
year
and what boris johnson describes as a
new beginning
with a global britain more power and
more
influence but could the opposite turn
out to be the case
a diminishing level of power and a
diminishing
influence by the end of 2021 we may have
an
idea andrew simmons al jazeera london